[Music]
you all knew this one was coming
oh and uh i know this is the wrong shirt
but i'm not getting that polka dot shirt
[Applause]
ever
[Music]
kill the moon one of the
most notorious episodes of this series
of capaldi's run by some estimates
possibly of new who in general
people really don't like this one
and now it's been a very long time since
i made this video i don't really stand
by its contents anymore but i do
remember
people shouting the name of this one
along with another one i'll be dealing
with later this
series as to why was this not on my list
of worst episodes of new who
oh boy so there's always a lot of
issues here and depending on who you ask
what the problem is varies quite
greatly so
there are some who will tell you
the problem is this is possibly the most
nonsense science that doctor who
has engaged in there are some
who say it is bad because of
the ham-fisted uh abortion allegory that
people
see in it and some people say it's
basically because it appears to be there
and some people will say it's bad
because it's poorly handled
i'm gonna do my best to try and tackle
all of these aspects
but there is a lot that doesn't quite
work here
that said it starts out fairly solid
i honestly am not entirely sure i get
why
courtney woods is in this episode not
to the extent that i was like why are
angie and already here for
nightmare and silver it's not that bad
and i know i said i kind of liked
like the little one-off trip the doctor
took her on at the end of the caretaker
but that didn't mean i wanted her coming
along
on another trip after that i don't
entirely know what her presence is meant
to serve other than to
i guess give a two to one vote on the on
the issue
among the three remaining characters
when the doctor just
waltzes off at uh towards the
back end of the episode that said she's
not the worst thing in the world
she's not super annoying i just don't
entirely know why she's there
i do like the atmosphere
and the sense of foreboding in the front
end of it
especially with things like the doctor
you know using the yoyo and be like
what's wrong with the moon
the gravity is wrong this should be this
should not be working like this this
shouldn't be working at all what's going
on and this notion of well the moon is a
heck of a lot denser than it should be
that is an interesting initial hook
and you know i also kind of like the
idea that
there are there's barely space faring
technology
i like the not that far in the future
and this idea that
people stopped caring about space travel
which honestly is something we've kind
of been seeing getting played out
in real life nasa keeps losing funding
and all the
you know new launches they're all
private
and private companies which this thing
even has you know the
the base that they go to it was a an
exploratory exposition they say from
mexico but i don't think they identify
it as being government they were there
for a mining survey i would buy that
that was private
so i i kind of like especially how
much the doctor as a character in the
show as a whole tends to emphasize this
idea of
humans off to take their destiny in
space but
like realistically there's at least
going to be a period where
we're just kind of ah space whatever
and i kind of like that this has that
going on as a background feature and and
it actually plays into the story as to
why they
landed this in this what is for them
really out of date piece of equipment
you know just
loaded up haphazardly with these bombs i
like how that element is worked into the
story and how it goes forward
once we start getting into what's
actually going
on that's when things start
to come apart so
oh boy so the moon is an egg
and there's moon spiders
for some reason yeah i know they're
identified as
bacteria which i suppose that'll
start with the uh the soft science
nightmare that this episode is
and like let me be clear i
i can deal with a lot of iffy science
from doctor who but
i prefer my iffy science to be a version
of
this is a piece of technology that just
does things that
probably technology isn't going ever
going to be able to accomplish
i can roll with that i can roll with
time travel faster than light travel to
sonic screwdriver i can roll with
all that they are futuristic advanced or
alien pieces of tech
that's fine where the show can lose me
is where it takes things that we have
actual scientific knowledge about
and just fudges it
really badly that's that's the kind of
soft science that i i
can take me out of the story so these
bacteria which first of all if they are
just bacteria
define that they look like spiders i
suppose but why are there webs
everywhere if they're not spiders
why are there why are there cobwebs all
over everything that never gets answered
so once we find out what these things
actually are
so that that's that's a nitpick that's a
that is a minor nitpick uh on this thing
trust me we got bigger fish to fry
but
this is going to sound really weird
because i can go with the idea of like
shrinking down for things like the test
selector into the dalek even if i don't
love it i'm like fine i'll roll with it
but
just because you're dealing with
something that is larger than normal
doesn't mean that all the other things
that would exist on that thing on a
normal scale are also scaled up
i.e bacteria is still microscopic
even if the egg that it's on is massive
bacteria does not suddenly become the
size
of a dalmatian that's
not how anything
works but again those things are really
just there to
give us a couple jump scares and take
out some of the team and that like
move on from those so
the egg and the debate
do we kill it so
the thing is i actually have not been
able to confirm
whether or not this is actually intended
to be
an allegory for abortion the pro-life
versus pro-choice debate i'm not 100
convinced that it is
and i'd heard word i feel like i'd read
somewhere but i couldn't dig it up again
that the writer uh who peter harness
had said that that was not his intent
with crafting the story to make it
an allegorical abortion story but i
couldn't as i said i couldn't find that
again
but even if he didn't intend it to be
that
it does read as that regardless
especially in the way the debate is
framed and
worded and the defenses
for or against it are going to draw that
comparison that being said if it
is meant to be an allegory for abortion
it's a really bad one
because it fails on its starting premise
because there are some hardcore
anti-abortion people who say never never
never never never
but most people the majority
by a pretty sizable amount agree that
abortion
is acceptable in a case where the
mother's life is at stake
and we are in a situation where the
lives of
untold millions on the planet
earth are at stake
so right off the bat if it's meant as an
allegory it
fails because it completely screwed
the stakes because normally the debate
would be
life of the dog life of the child
versus life of the parent and now it's
life of the child
versus millions if not billions of lives
and that's not what the debate in
reality
is so if it's meant as an allegory it
fails on its face just on premise
so that's the first problem with that if
it is intended
and again if it isn't they really needed
to take another pass
and scrub some of the things on here
because the fact that arguments against
killing it are things like but it's a
baby
it's not doing anything harmful it
doesn't mean to hurt anybody
you don't have a right to kill it these
are pro-life arguments and i'm not
here to debunk or try and settle
pro-choice versus pro-life
but it really it
uses language that evokes that debate so
if that was not the intent
they then they screwed up there they
screwed up one of two ways
either in failing to have a properly
constructed allegory
or in failing to realize that they'd
created
one unintentionally either one of those
should have been caught and corrected
i'm not sure which it is but
somewhere they screwed up and i also
don't know what
what the moral on this is supposed to be
it's really weird because
clara and courtney make their arguments
if it was a democratic system they out
vote
you know the woman who's there with the
bomb but it's not
she basically puts it to the planet the
entire planet says
kill this thing and she then disregards
it
so i don't i don't know what to think
about clara
in this situation because
she's clearly just on a moral high horse
and has already decided what the right
thing to do is
and if everyone in the world says
no that's not the right thing to do
she's still gonna do it anyway
and save this thing and if she's already
determined that
it's kind of just
cowardly i was gonna say patronizing but
it's not it's cowardly that she would
even put it up to a vote
because she intends to override it
anyways
but she doesn't want to be put in that
position she's hoping that they will
bail her
out and i don't
i don't get what this is trying to say
about clara
i'm not sure it says anything about the
strength of her character convictions
because she tries to cheap out to not
have to make that call herself
she's hoping that they will that they
will side with her and make that
choice easier for her and when they
don't she does ultimately make it
and so ultimately it feels like a wash
she's strong by her convictions to
ultimately override
the desire of literally every other
person on the planet
but she is weak enough in her
convictions at the same time
to not just put her foot down and say
this is what it is i guess in some ways
it's a very human
response you know hoping that you won't
have to make the tough decision but
ultimately i feel like it's not really
telling us anything about
her all that much and it feels like it
should
so that's part of the problem i don't
know
i don't know what the doctor was trying
to accomplish
when he left i do
like some of the things that gets
said when he makes the decision to
leave you know when he says i can't just
make these decisions for you i can't
just change
things on a whim we went to dinner in
berlin in 1937 we didn't pop off after
putting and kill hitler and you wouldn't
expect me to do that
the future is is no more malleable than
the past
as far as the doctor is concerned that's
a decent argument inconsistent with how
the doctor
has been and behaved across the run of
the show
but internally consistent for the
episode and a decent way of presenting
that argument
um but it only works within the bubble
of this episode
and it's so the here was the
thing that made me lose it first time i
watched this and it's just as stupid
it's not the fact that the moon is an
egg
it's not the fact that there is this
ham-fisted
you know debate that is either a poorly
handled allegory or
an accidental allegory that somebody
should have caught it's not
even that the
moon cracks open and crumbles to dust
instead of having
shrapnel rain down on earth
none of that is great but all that i'd
be like
eh what made me go are you
kidding me when i saw this
for the first time and again on this
re-watch
is that the space dragon
which is just what i'm gonna call it
immediately after being born
lays another egg
the same size about maybe a little
smaller
it it laid an egg that looked
bigger than it was and it sure as heck
didn't look
born pregnant and
it removes any consequences
at all and that ultimately especially if
this is meant to be
uh an allegory for abortion that is what
completely
fails and brings it down to everything
is the lack of
consequences because look let's for the
moment say that this is
intended to be an allegory for abortion
that decision to either
bring a pregnancy to term or to abort
either choice has consequences
personal deep emotional
consequences as well as severe logistic
consequences
so to do an allegorical story on
abortion where there are no consequences
is to completely misunderstand
the issue at hand because anyone who's
ever been
in that position neither choice is
easy and it is
and it is a difficult thing to make but
whatever you choose there are
consequences for that there is no
obvious
we do this and everything's fine choice
if you're in a position where that
option is on the table
so that's where it completely falls down
and even if it isn't an allegory for
abortion the fact that
clara just overrode the desires of
literally the entire planet
that should have consequences even if
we're not doing
an allegory for abortion that
should have consequences but it doesn't
because the moon no part of the moon
crashes
the moon's not even gone it's
immediately replaced with another egg
moon what
because at the very least at the very
least
there should have been the consequence
of we have no moon anymore
the tides don't happen anymore this will
impact the planet we are going to have
to learn how to change and adapt
and deal with a changed world because
the moon and the impact of the moon on
this planet
have been with us for the entire history
of our species and now it's gone oh no
wait it isn't it's still there
i hate big event with no
consequence if you're not going to have
consequence do not do an event that
big i have the same problem with the
last of the time lords
and the rolling back of the year so that
the entire invasion of earth
basically doesn't happen and like only
what six people
remember what happened if you're not
going to play out the consequences
don't do something that
big just don't because if you
do if you're going to destroy the moon
you have to have consequences
not go oh well thank goodness this thing
was born pregnant and immediately laid
an egg in the exact same
freaking place it was just born how
stupid you think i
am that having been said
i really like the argument between the
doctor and clara
it is emotional it is heated
it feels justified that's a really good
scene and i like
that clara goes to danny to basically
tell him that the doctor pushed me into
a situation that was not okay and i was
not okay with
because she promised him that she would
do that if the doctor ever did that to
her and he did
and she kept that promise i like that as
well
there aren't any consequences on the
grand narrative but there
are some consequences
to the dr and clara's relationship
in theory because the next episode kicks
off and they're just
together on an adventure like it's
treated like oh well this is the last
one but i'm sorry if you have a complete
and total breakdown of a relationship in
a way that feels like
immense emotional abuse you don't go on
one more
trip so even that scene which is a good
scene
and is well played
the consequences don't last
man this thing's frustrating kill the
moon
you rewatched it lately if you did what
you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something on down in the comments let's
talk about it usual stuff to do
no it is like subscribe patreon that's
really kind of big right now the the
assistance is kind of needed but
if you're not able to liking commenting
sharing
all that stuff still helps and i've got
social media links and other things down
there
give them a look or don't
end of the day you're the council i just
won the meetings and until next time
this council
is adjourned
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]